if you've visited wikipedia an
e-commerce site or your favorite blog
there's a really good chance that a lamp
stack was responsible for delivering
that page content to you
well what does that mean it is a web
platform
made of four different components the
first of which is linux the operating
system
the second is apache
which is a web server
third
mysql
a database and finally p
for php which is a programming language
and runtime environment
to understand how these work together
let's do a simple example of what
happened when we retrieved that page
so you were in your browser
and you made a url which does a get
request to a server
installed on that server are these
different components the first of which
is linux
that is routed to a web server in this
case apache
apache has installed on it a number of
web applications
that handle the different requests to
the different websites that that web
server handles and those are written in
php
it handles both the business logic and
the presentation logic
formatting the entire page and returning
it to the user
to do that it relies on a database to
gather the information that you've asked
for using mysql
so that the only gives you that overall
picture of it
but there are alternatives to the lamp
stack which are becoming more and more
popular
two of which
is called the mean stack and the other
one's called the mirn stack
now we have other videos are going to go
into more details but i want to call out
specifically why these are unique
the r and the a
the a is for angular and the r is free
act
and react and angular
are javascript that's installed on the
browser
and then instead of requesting a page
from the server and getting back the all
the content in one chunk it uses
rest apis
to simply ask for the data and then the
data is formatted on the page on demand
and there are trade-offs of those in far
in terms of being able to do a
responsive user interface maybe speed we
have a separate video that will cover
that in more detail it'll help you
decide which is the right stack for your
application
whoa wait a second remember those videos
i talked about they're right here